موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله فجرت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
منزلا يعود لعائله الاسير اسلام الفروخ
وسط مدينه رام الله وذلك بتهمه التخطيط
وتنفيذ عمليتي تفجير متزامنتين في محطتين
حافلات في مدينه القدس قتل فيها
اسرائيليان في شهر نوفمبر الماضي هذا
واصيب سته عشر فلسطينيا بينهم صحافيون على
اثر اطلاق جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
الرصاصه الحيه والمعدنيه على مئات
الفلسطينيين في قلب مدينه رام الله قبل
تنفيذ عمليه الهدم
قال حاكم خيرسون
600 كيلومتر مربع من المقاطعه غمر في
المياه بعد تفجير السد كخوفك جنوبيه
اوكرانيا هذا واظهرت صور من داخل المدينه
الاثار الناجمه عن تدمير سد نوفاك خوفك
جنوبي البلاد وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان
المدينه تعيش ظروفا صعبه بعدما غمرت
المياه معظم اجزائها جراء التفجير السمت
هذا وحضرت منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للام المتحده من احتمالات التفاقم الجوع
في العالم وحدوث تداعيات بعيده المدى
بيئيا وانسانيا جراء تفجير السد وقلل
المتحدث باسم الامن العام للامم المتحده
ستيفاندوير السبت سيؤثر بشكل سلبي على
الامن الغذائي في العالم بعد تدمير
الفيضانات الاف الهكتارات من الاراضي
الزراعيه
افاد موقع
العسكري الروسي بان القوات الروسيه احبطت
هجوما اوكرانيا عند منطقه خزانه
اضاف الموقع ان القوات الروسيه احبطت
الليله الماضيه ايضا هجوما اوكرانيا واسعا
على محور توك ماك واوريخوفا في مقاطعه ذا
فالوجيا واكد انه تم اجبار القوات
الاوكرانيه على التراجع
افدى مراسل الجزيره في السودان بتجدد
اشتعال النيران بكثافه للمره الثانيه في
مواقع الاشتباكات بالقرب من المستودعات
الرئيسيه لمخازن الغاز والوقود جنوبيه
الخرطوم تثير هذه الاشتباكات الخوف من
اندلاع حرائق كبيره لقربها من خزانات وقود
ضخمه
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ابن الوزير ان
يجتمع مع ناظره السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان في الرياض واقل بيان للخارجيه من
الجانبين تعهد بمواصله تعاونهما القوي
لانهاء القتال في السودان
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الجويه الروسيه والصينيه نفذت مناورات
مشتركه في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادر
واكدت الوزاره في بياننا المناورات
المشتركه تاتي في اطار خطه التعاون
العسكري بين البلدين العام الجاري وليست
موجهه ضد احد لكن اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
نقلت للجانبين مخاوفها بشان تحركاتهما
انتهى الموجزا ما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]